wir haben ja alle gesehen die rede von
wladimir putin am 9 mai bei der großen
militärparade in moskau er hat dort eine
erstaunliche moderator rede gehalten er
hat keine
keine eskalation des krieges der ukraine
angekündigt und wenn man dorthin schaut
auf das schlachtfeld kann man
feststellen es gibt dort kaum mehr
bewegung also es sieht so aus als hätten
sich die beiden armeen erschöpft und als
gäbe es eine art von cut auf dem
schlachtfeld das heißt jetzt ist es zeit
darüber nachzudenken wie kommt man aus
diesem krieg raus ich glaube dass keiner
der beiden in der lage ist in anderen zu
überwältigen jetzt gibt es in der
deutschen debatte die jetzt begonnen hat
zwei verschiedene thesen die erste sagt
oder arbeitet mit der formel die ukraine
muss siegen die fdp militärexperten
schlafzimmer man beispielsweise sagt
diesen satz immer wieder was verbirgt
sich dahinter muss genau hinhören und
wissen was damit gemeint ist gemeint ist
damit dass die russische armee aus der
ukraine rausgeworfen wird und zwar
vollständig so dass die ukraine in der
alten form wiederhergestellt wird
inklusive krim und inklusive oslo keine
das würde aber glaube ich ein sehr
langen krieg erfordern wenn es überhaupt
möglich ist ich halte das für
illusorisch die zweite these lautet gibt
es zwei sätze die ukraine darf nicht
verlieren und putin darf nicht gewinnen
olaf scholz sagt beide sätze die sind
interessant da muss man drüber nach was
man eigentlich damit wenn man wenn der
einen nicht verlieren und der andere
nicht gewinnen darf dann ist man
irgendwie inbetween ja das heißt man
muss eine lösung finden mit der beide
leben können und diese lösung lautet
teilung der ukraine und zwar ungefähr
entlang der fronten die jetzt fast
erreicht sind wenn die russische armee
in der ost ukraine weiter ein bisschen
vorangeht ist sie da angekommen dass sie
die ostukrainische vollständig in besitz
genommen hat und dann wäre der zeitpunkt
gekommen um einen waffenstillstand zu
schließen und eine dauerhafte regelung
zu finden die würde sagen wenn man die
ukraine teilt die russen bekommen die
krim endgültig den land gürtel der
entlang von dort aus entlang am
asowschen meer mittendrin liegt mario
pohl bis nach russland führt
und die ost ukraine sogenannten don was
bleibt russisch umgekehrt ist die rest
ukraine oder sagen wir besser die west
ukraine der größte teil des landes
bleibt
selbstständig wird garantiert in seiner
existenz von verschiedenen großmächten
darf in die eu eintreten allerdings
nicht in die nato wird neutralisiert und
ist damit dauerhaft lebensfähig diese
lösung
davon bin ich überzeugt will auch olaf
scholz hat sie im hinterkopf darüber
redet man jetzt nicht weil man dann
lange argumentieren müsste man muss nur
sehen wie sich die dinge militärische
entwickeln und dann kann man in der
entscheidenden minute sagen dahin muss
die sache laufen olaf scholz will das
deshalb weil er auch der überzeugung ist
dass man eine gesichtswahrende lösung
für putin finden muss uns gibt es keinen
frieden und der nachteil dieser lösung
es
natürlich dass
das der aggressor belohnt wird das
erfreute macht das muss man klar sagen
auf der anderen seite ist es aus
heutiger sicht die einzige möglichkeit
um frieden zu erreichen
frank klapper ist ein ganzes land
frieden ohne die gesichtswahrung putins
überhaupt möglich jeden fall sagen mir
ist die gesichtswahrung von putin total
egal und wenn er dann rauswerfen könnten
wäre ich dabei
wirklich auch wenn er sein gesicht dann
verliert wer erstmal ist putin
unberechenbar und wer sagt uns denn wenn
er was wenn er das zugeworfen kriegt vor
die füße geworfen kriegt was er sich
nehmen wollte dass er dann ruhe hält bei
der krim hat er auch nicht ruhe gehalten
also ich bin da hoch skeptisch und
deshalb unterstütze ich sehr
waffenlieferungen an die ukraine damit
die ukraine sich verteidigen kann es
geht nicht um angriffs geht nicht um
angriffswaffen stasi dass die ukraine
sich irgendeinem land holt aber wir
müssen noch mal normal dass wir mal
wieder den klaren blick bekommen da ist
ein
diktator der für sich entscheidet mir
reichten die grenzen meines landes nicht
und ich nehme mal was vom anderen aber
doch raus aus dem land das aussehen das
ist doch ein widerspruch
was sie lesen wollen russland besiegen
auf dem schlachtfeld aber ja naja was
heißt sie ich meine es ist glaub ich hab
mal sagt er darf nicht segen oder die
anderen dürfen mit sägen noch mal wir
haben einen zustand wo sich jemand etwas
was überhaupt nicht was nicht im
völkerrecht entspricht was wir
sind ja auch fake news also die
behauptung er sei nahezu angegriffen
worden russland und all diese
geschichten ich glaube putin kein wort
egal was man mit ihm auch vereinbart und
deshalb sage ich sehr klar wir sehen
dass das was putin sich vorgenommen
hatte was er glaubt als würde er noch
empfange wohl jubel kaum zu träumen ja
aber er dachte er würde ja noch bio bio
empfangen werden als große erlöser das
ist nicht aufgegangen und er sieht er
auch und das kostet auch ressourcen
russland und aus dem grund sag ich sehe
uns stets überhaupt mit zu herr jahre
ist glaube ich uns stets nicht zu der
ukraine zu sagen oder eine präsidentin
seelands geht das mal auf das gibt dir
jetzt ab doch vollkommen tsunami-warnung
ski und entschuldige mich das anwenden
darf dagegen selensky und putin waren ja
bei den verhandlungen der türkei schon
fast so weit dass zu vereinbaren also
seelands geld auch gesehen er muss was
geben damit der krieg aufhört das ist
gescheitert wahrscheinlich weil es zu
früh war also putin hatte sich noch
nicht genug geholt jetzt kommen wir eine
situation wo er sich auch angesichts der
schwäche seiner armee mit irgendwas
zufrieden geben muss bevor er ganz leer
ausgeht ganz leer geht aber nicht nach
hause wir haben die wahl zwischen einem
sehr langen krieg oder einem krieg der
die ukraine im kern land stabilisiert in
den westen führt in die eu integriert
oder einem dauerhaften krieg der das
land total zerstört mit einem russland
im hintergrund dass immer noch so stark
ist dass ich es für unbesiegbar halte
auch wenn ja es gibt aber noch eine
dimension die dürfen wir nicht vergessen
und die dimension sagt
wie können wir als europäer als
wertegemeinschaft auch abschreckend
wirken in der zukunft es geht nicht nur
um die ukraine ich bin jemand der kriege
erlebt und ich weiß dass kriege enden
das ist ganz viel
schreckliches passiert für die menschen
die diese krieg erleben wir sitzen ja
hier in unseren friedlichen ort und
diskutieren darüber aber wenn wir wollen
dass solche taten nicht
nachahmer haben und wir haben ja in der
welt ganz viele diktatoren die auch mit
dieser idee spielen und diese fantasien
haben das lohnt sich nicht und da
mussten wir stärker zeigen und stärker
bedeutet waffenlieferung stärker
bedeutet aggression lohnt sich nicht
aber ich glaube damit muss und wie das
gerät verloren einmal ganz groß auf der
position und bevor wir weiter zu
blockieren glauben sie putin wie stehen
sie dazu
also ich bin ein bisschen zerrissen
innerlich ich bin grundsätzlich der
auffassung dass waffenlieferungen nicht
gut sind wir sollten uns eigentlich eher
aus der rüstungsindustrie komplett
zurückziehen ich habe das schon vor vier
fünf jahren gesagt von wegen die die
rüstungsindustrie
hochfahren die das thema von uns
erwartet hat ich war komplett dagegen
ich bin einer der erstunterzeichner die
gesagt haben keine rüstungsindustrie
hochfahren es gibt natürlich auch
statements auch aus ihrer parteien der
ist zum beispiel um die rückseiten
rüstungsexporte bezüglich des jemen geht
wo man sagt auf keinen fall rüstung oder
waffen liefern und eine riesengrosse fis
muss ist kommt man mich ganz lassen sie
mich kurz ich bin ich bin sicher
pazifistin und ich will auch nicht
zusehen wenn irgendwo irgendwann krieg
stattfindet aber es ist wie gesagt keine
lösung aus meiner sicht wenn man noch
massive waffen in das land rein bringt
ich halte
deeskalation politik und friedenspolitik
und alle parteien an einen tisch am
besten noch mit dem uno-generalsekretär
für die glücklicheren lösung das finden
wir das finde ich sehr wichtig aber ist
vom busfahrer holt ja auch nicht so dass
ich war ja damals erfand werden möchte
ich hätte den brief von alice schwarzer
niemals unterschrieben ich auch ich
halte den für eine kapitulation
dabei hätte ich niemals gemacht ich
glaube man muss putin entgegen drin ich
hätte ihren brief unterschrieben sind
die hand sie haben den antwortbrief vor
gelassen und da ich bin für
waffenlieferungen und auch von schweren
waffen und zwar nicht nur altes gerät
wie das aus deutschland jetzt an liefern
sondern modernes gerät mit dem die auch
sofort umgehen können denn was die
bundesregierung tut ist doch sagt ist
doch eine schande also diesen alten gepa
panzer der nicht mehr fahrbereit ist und
für den es keine munition mehr gibt ja
universums oder wir den tieren mord ja
natürlich
ja natürlich also entschuldigung aber
auch aber frieden aber auch wie ein
starker milliarde arbeiten wir auch
britische sage doch ich sage doch das
meine ich damit wir nähern uns einem
zustand wo putin vielleicht einsieht
dass er nicht weiterkommt mit der
aggression weil die ukraine wieder steht
weiter kommt er nicht als unten diesen
landstreifen und die krim zu halten und
die ost ukraine die überwiegend russisch
spricht russisch orientiert ist das hat
ja angela merkel mit dem minsker
abkommen versucht innerhalb der ukraine
zu lösen sehr kompliziert ein autonomer
status innerhalb der kanal ist nicht
funktionieren dürfen nicht vergessen
dass frauen eigentlich gerade mit ihrer
position
das kann ich nachvollziehen schon dass
wir das nehme ich nicht so pauschal
nicht erst bringen sich dazwischen
werfen denn so wie ich wahrgenommen
haben sie bauchschmerzen damit ich
glaube also ich als parlamentarierin die
zugestimmt hat waffen zu liefern ich
mache mir damit auch nicht einfach
genauso wenig wie die kolleginnen und
kollegen das ist nichts banales man
sagen wir schicken malweise die drachen
sind einfach nur zum spielen da ist ich
mache einen ganz klaren unterschied ob
jemand jemanden angreift oder ob jemand
angegriffen wird und seine kinder seine
leute verteilen wir da werden menschen
vergewaltigt dann werden menschen die
folgerung foltert aber inzwischen sehen
sich auch noch nie gehabt aus wenigen
anderen starken nochmal geräten über die
ukraine wir sind hier in sicherheit ja
wir sind hier in sicherheit und sagen
der ukraine also es mit dem
waffenlieferung finden wir nicht gut die
haben keine andere chance gerade ich
rede ist zynisch also freiheiten hat den
deutschen der schläger wort zu dem thema
es gab vor vier jahren gab es die
statistik das glaube ich die
bundesrepublik deutschland viertgrösster
waffenexporteur der welt war richtig ich
glaube jetzt ist er nummer eins oder
nummer zwei also mit den 100 milliarden
das ist praktisch durch die decke ich
erinnere an den waffenstillstands
vertrag mit den alle der vor vielen
vielen jahrzehnten gemacht wurde aus
einem ganz guten wichtigen grund und wir
haben uns als staatsgebilde als
demokratie dem frieden verpflichtet wir
würden das normalerweise auch tun wenn
das nicht die ukraine näher ich sage bis
jetzt ist es ja immer so gewesen dass
man gesagt hat ihm jemand passiert
irgendwas da passiert was dort passiert
was wir wollen frieden frieden frieden
frieden jetzt plötzlich schreien alle
nach waffenlieferungen okay
waren afghanistan
was ich auch gut fand auch da sozusagen
die werte unseres landes auch so kämpfen
wir haben auch uns beteiligt an kriege
und ich glaube das ist sehr sehr
utopisch zu glauben dass frieden einfach
so existiert das man nicht was
anzubieten es gibt doch es gibt nach dem
zweiten weltkrieg verschiedene verträge
die man miteinander gemacht hat unter
anderen dem zivilpakt 1 unter anderem
artikel 20 in artikel 20 heißt es darf
keine kriegspropaganda gemacht werden es
dürfen keine keine er sei aber keine
propaganda in dieser richtung gemacht
werden es dürfen keine deutschland ein
einer kriegspropaganda grundsätzlich
sollte man sich aus allem heraushalten
das hat eine historie und ich persönlich
bin ich bin bestimmt nicht die einzige
aber hier in dieser runde ich bin der
auffassung wir brauchen die eskalation
und friedenspolitik und zwar die die wir
in den 90ern gekannt haben und die wir
in den achtzigern gekannt haben und
davor
ein 1 1 und jugendlichenalter letzte
wort der neben corona und neben dem
ukraine krieg beschäftigt uns auch die
inflationssorgen film nine und russland
entscheiden welche lösung zu finden und
niemand und es steht also heißt
zuschauer zwar unglücklich wenn man ihm
einen anderen nicht das letzte wort über
lässt sich